we think that the best professors in the
world will be teaching thousands maybe
hundreds of thousands of students hi I'm
Nicolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with Alex Tabarrok of
marginal revolution he's a professor of
economics at George Mason University
Alex thanks for speaking with us you
have just started marginal revolution
University tell us what you're offering
online so we have a whole online
education platform but our first course
is going to be on development economics
an entire course on development
economics taught in less than half the
time available for free to the entire
world
so and when you say it's an entire
course it's lectures and interaction
with professors or how does that work
so it's video based it'll be very
similar to Khan Academy so no talking
heads and so you won't see our faces all
of the time but you'll be getting full
information a full course in that sense
and what do you hope I mean obviously
online education is big and growing but
so are questions about the cost
efficiency of higher education you're
offering this online for free what are
you hoping to kind of accomplish with
marginal revolution University so I
think there's two things first of all
the entire world is in need of more
education and there's going to be over a
billion new students in the next few
years so we think that in just the same
way that lots of people in Africa have
left to sell phones instead of to
landlines leave that technological
border we think they can do the same
thing with online education so that's
one market the other kind of market is
here in the United States as you pointed
out the cost of education is going way
up and we think that the online tools
are going to allow people including us
to do it not just at a lower monetary
cost but at a lower time cost as well
you don't have to pay for parking for
our class or look for a space but what
people pay for a lot in education is the
diploma so you know is there a diploma
and will people value say a diploma for
marginal revolution University you
graduate Phi Beta Kappa summa [ __ ] laude
whatever but if you didn't pay for it
will people value
the experience or even the knowledge you
gave I think there's definitely people
will value a credential absolutely so
there's large part of education is
credentialism we hope to move into that
this is the first step and we think that
this tool could be used we don't think
this is going to end universities we
think universities are gonna be around
for a long time and what we've done with
our first course at Marshall Revolution
University is develop chunks so
professors will be able to use parts of
this in their own courses you know grab
a section and say watch this for
homework then we'll talk more about it
in class so we see this as complementary
to a regular education as well as a
social talk a little bit I mean you
write about higher education and you
know the higher education bubble which I
think everybody admits that there's an
inflated you know cost but also kind of
population in higher education because
of various factors what do you see is
the future of high education is it going
to be a kind of admixture of free online
stuff you know traditional credentials
residency programs where do you see
higher education kind of going over the
next five or ten years you know I think
what's going to happen is I use Michael
Sandow as a key example you know he
taught his class on philosophy taught it
on PBS taught it to you know hundred
thousand students and I think that model
of the world's best professors are going
to teach more students and instead of
having every university you know an
adjunct professor teaching principles of
economics or teaching development
economics it's going to be more of a
winner-take-all market so this is a case
where leverage really matters so we
think that the best professors in the
world will be teaching thousands maybe
hundreds of thousands of students around
the world so it'd be much more
hierarchical winner-take-all kind of
market what's gonna be the second third
fourth course that you offer online a
lot of it depends upon demand so we're
gonna see what people are interested in
and take it from there all right well
thank you very much for talking with
reason TV Alex Tabarrok
the I don't know are you the Provost of
marginal revolution University or the
President or co-president and also of
course of George Mason
Economics Department in Virginia Alex
thanks for talking to us good talking
with you for a reason TV I'm Nicholas P